Hey, what's up. You guys,
I'm Gabriel Iglesias and I'm about to answer the internet.
So my show is called mystery glass. Yes. It comes out on Netflix, uh, June 21st,
if this is after June 21st, it is streaming now. So check it out and, uh, yeah,
let's see what happens.
[Inaudible].
Would you rather know when you're going to die or how you're going
to die? I'd rather know how I'm going to die,
because that will determine my diet.
Would you rather be stuck in Jumanji or Jurassic park?
Uh, you know what?
I think that there's more things that could kill you in Jumanji than in Jurassic
park. The most random things can get you in Jumanji. So I'm, uh,
I'm going to go with trying to outrun a dinosaur. Uh,
you're in a car chase, let's say you're in a car chase with the police.
What song is playing in your car? Uh, something by [inaudible],
which is a Mexican band. Uh, basically it's like gangster rap in Spanish,
kind of cause that's the type of songs they sing.
And if you're trying to outrun the cops,
it'd be kind of cool to be hearing some of these songs in Spanish while you're
like, you can have one thing free for the rest of your life.
What would you choose Starbucks? Yeah, I'm one of those.
All right. If you were stuck inside of a,
if you were stuck inside of a food that you had to eat your way out of
what would you choose.
A donut all day.
And you get offered a billion dollars to never leave the state.
Of Ohio. Do you take it? Ooh.
Billion dollars as it is. You can buy a lot with five. Um,
you probably own the whole state of Ohio for a billion dollars.
I'd take it. I've been there. They've got a Bob Bevins and they also got a, uh,
you know, I, I could, I could, for a billion dollars,
I could bring my favorite restaurants and open them in Ohio.
Like they don't have that. They will, when I'm done with them.
And for that much money, I can buy my own neighbors. Uh, I think I'd be happy.
I'd be cool. Billion bucks. You can do a lot. I, you know, I don't go there now.
I don't go there. Now. You're going to miss the beaches. I'll buy paintings.
Would you rather date a girl who laughs at everything or nothing?
I'd say everything because I've,
I've dated the other one and it didn't work out.
You get to marry the girl of your dreams,
but you have to watch your biggest enemy have sex with
her first. Do you do it?
Wow.
You guys are up.
[Inaudible].
I don't think I could get that mentally out of my head. That'd be,
that'd be weird. Uh, yeah, no. Cause he could always say like, you know,
if he's my biggest enemy, he could always look at me and be like full.
I had her first.
Would you rather have a Dick as your
nose or a nose as your Dick?
You'd.
Like me to answer this I'm sure.
I guess if I had to choose,
I'm going to go with it.
Dick, uh, knows Dick. I'm going to go, go with a nose Dick.
Just, you know, so I can have a normal life.
Somewhat. Yeah.
But yeah, I'll walk it around now. Yeah.
What's on your pads. I got a cold.
Uh, would you rather prove aliens are real or prove
ghosts are real well, I have my own conspiracies, uh,
but uh, I I'd rather prove that ghosts are real.
Go on with the conspiracy
[inaudible] Oh, here we go. Ah, I don't think.
Alone in this universe. I, I don't. I think it's it's it's you know,
for us to think we're the only ones that happen to be around that's no, man,
you know, even Ohio has, has people that well, nevermind.
We're not alone people. We're not alone.